[Musica]
il suono che state ascoltando è il canto
di un lui piccolo un volatile
passeriforme di non più di 11 centimetri
grande viaggiatore che attraversa buona
parte dell'europa per arrivare a
svernare nell'africa settentrionale nel
suo attraversamento tocca vari punti tra
cui i nostri territori
l'italia è anche questi territori
mi piacciono anche le zone umide e lui
piccolo nel suo modo di interpretare la
vita ci insegna una cosa ci insegna a
utilizzare il paesaggio come la migliore
infrastruttura collega appunti
cosa c'entra questo con quello che vi
sto per raccontare adesso lo scopriremo
però ho bisogno di uno sforzo di
immaginazione perché la cosa che vado da
cosa di cui vado parlando è vagamente
complesso è un sistema complesso però
cercheremo di semplificarlo la prima il
primo sforzo di immaginazione che vi
chiedo e questo immaginatevi una persona
meglio mi immagino una anna una donna
che vive in una fascia periurbana quindi
non in centro città margine per la
campagna un appartamento si sveglia al
mattino suo figlio piccolo va preparato
l'azione si veste veste anzi non veste
trio piccolo fa vestire perché il pd
bimbi anche da piccoli devono essere
autonomi e poi lo accompagnano compagni
appena fuori casa perché fuori casa cosa
c'è c'è un bicibus una carovana di
biciclette che si inoltra con altri
bimbi di un adulto e va verso una
stazione ferroviaria tempo di
percorrenza 2 minuti
grosso modo stazione ferroviaria di
porta a scuola
tempo di percorrenza 9 11 minuti dipende
dopodichè
anna torna indietro torna a casa si
riassetta un po chiude la porta prende a
bicicletta e va nell'approdo più vicino
che a tre minuti di biciclette sale con
la barca sull'approdo e attraverso
l'acqua arriva in centro città scendere
la bicicletta e va al lavoro tutto
chiaro anna non esiste ovviamente per il
momento manna c'è già
probabilmente anche tra noi cosa succede
succede che anna è l'emblema della
visione strategica di cui sto per
parlarvi metropoli di paesaggio
metropoli paesaggio utilizza parte dal
principio incontrovertibile di
valorizzare utilizzare meglio
valorizzare il paesaggio come la nostra
migliore infrastruttura questo porta
delle conseguenze interessanti perché se
il paesaggio non è più quello che
ricordavamo in modo più o meno romantico
da contemplare sicuramente a tutelare
certamente non incidere nella migliore
delle ipotesi perché in italia abbiamo
inciso parecchio purtroppo sul paesaggio
e non nei termini piu corretti allora se
il paesaggio e questa cosa qui forse il
paesaggio ci dà una chiave di lettura
diversa del nostro quotidiano e ci
permette attraverso la valorizzazione
delle linee dei trasporti in questo caso
intermodali e sostenibili quindi sto
parlando di terra e di acqua e quindi
sto parlando di bicicletta quindi reti
ciclabili
sto parlando di vie d'acqua quindi
imbarcazioni sto parlando anche di treno
divine ferrovia e ma anche di strade se
percorsa ad esempio da bus elettrici ci
permette di avere una rete sovrapposto
di almeno quattro livelli che coprono in
modo capillare un territorio intero
facciamo un esempio ferrara c'è comodo
perché siamo partiti da qui la provincia
di ferrara si sapranno nei 2600 che
quell'atto 2.600 chilometri quadrati non
sono pochissimi e sono di alto livello
paesaggistico pensate che almeno un
quinto di questi 2.600 chilometri
quadrati sono tutelati vincolati unesco
mab unesco
sic zps non entro nel tecnico ma
paesaggio importante ma anche quattro
quinti che non sono tutelati sono una
bellezza e bene pensate a questa terra è
irradiata da reti che esistono già e che
bisogna solo riattivare e completare e
ricucire per avere un tessuto
funzionante in mobilità sostenibile
intermodale che è quello di chi sto
parlando
questa cosa non riguarda solo un cambio
di modalità di trasporto riguarda un
cambio di paradigma culturale è come se
noi interpretassi mo la città rispetto
alla campagna rispetto al territorio non
come l'abbiamo interpretata fino adesso
cioè con una dicotomia chiara di qualità
di quella campagna fine le due cose non
si toccano quando si toccano si fanno
del male
proviamo a pensare invece che città e
territorio che la raccoglie siano un
unicum parte di un unico sistema un
unico sistema che viaggia e che fa
viaggiare soprattutto persone flussi di
merci flussi di persone le fa collegare
le fa connettere le fa raggiungere i
luoghi anche più marginali e soprattutto
di far aggiungere sostituendo ai
chilometri distanza i tempi di
percorrenza
ecco se noi arriviamo apprezzare questo
arriviamo pensare anche che quel
paesaggio che non è più da contemplare
può essere il nostro migliore amico il
nostro migliore alleato nel nostro
quotidiano e forse può esserlo anche in
un periodo come questo che definiremo
più che può skovde gov.it a giudicare
anche delle mascherine forse forse
riusciamo a pensare anche finalmente al
vuoto in modo un po più orientale da
filosofia orientale cioè non al vuoto
come un abisso come the horror the
horror joseph conrad cuore di tenebra
frasi finali
scusate ho fatto spoiler in effetti
perché sulla letto però è il vuoto non
fa paura il vuoto il nostro migliore
alleato in questo caso è proprio in
tempi di kobe quando
la quantità di spazio diventa
incredibilmente qualità
la prima qualità ecco che muoversi nel
paesaggio utilizzare il paesaggio come
la nostra migliore infrastruttura forse
può cambiare il paradigma culturale con
cui affrontiamo il quotidiano mi chiedo
un secondo sforzo di immaginazione
a questo punto città e territorio
abbiamo detto unicum benissimo
pensiamo a un unico piano orizzontale
allora dove non esiste più campania
esiste ancora chiaramente si supera la
città ci mancherebbe altro però dove
dove tutto è connesso e tutto è connesso
secondo le quattro modalità di cui
parlavo prima
ebbene cosa otteniamo non otteniamo più
una città e dei comuni dei paesi
otteniamo semplicemente una unica
metropoli una metropoli di paesaggio
fatta da un centro nel caso la provincia
di ferrara sempre per il ritorno a
comodo questo esempio la città di
ferrara stessa il quartiere principale e
poi una serie di altri quartieri non
secondari e tutti collegati tra loro che
sono i vari comuni e frazioni i borghi
collegati l'uno all'altro illogica
policentrica una specie di policentrismo
dolce diffuso nel territorio non
invasivo non invasivo come come come in
tanti esempi che abbiamo avuto nella
storia dell'urbanistica contemporanea
per pensiamo al resto della pianura
padana
ad esempio tutti i distretti industriali
che hanno subito pesanti interventi sul
paesaggio dove appunto paesaggio si
ridimensiona fazzoletti metropoli
paesaggio è un ossimoro che spiega come
cambiano si sovvertono completamente le
proporzioni tra quantità di paesaggio e
quantità di urbanizzato è troppo ripresa
ciò è una città non di non fondazione ma
che già esiste in filigrana nei
territori in cui il paesaggio è
abbondantemente superiore antropizzato e
ci permette di vivere meglio e ci
permette di connettersi meglio
allora a questo punto perché dobbiamo
utilizzare questa rete potrebbe non
essere convincente quello che sto
dicendo
pensiamo però a una cosa pensiamo ad
esempio a a quello che ci dice l'europa
new green deal green new deal
ebbene ci dicono report della
commissione europea smarcato alla fine
del 2019 mese sta parlando
abbondantemente dobbiamo ridurre le
emissioni di ossido di carbonio ridurre
le polveri sottili
dobbiamo contrastare i cambiamenti
climatici e il degrado ambientale però
non poco ma lì si è capaci non ne sono
così sicuro
cioè tutto molto interessante ma ne
abbiamo veramente voglia durante durante
la quarantena
noi abbiamo assistito alla diverse
declinazioni di questa storia ad esempio
ricordo parigi la città dei 15 minuti no
anni dal go la sindaca di parigi e
carlos moreno che è il sociologo che
sostanzialmente ha inventato quella
struttura di pensieri e noi ce la
potremmo anche fare quella città dei 15
minuti potrebbe diventare il territorio
dei venti minuti ma quale condizione o
meglio a quali condizioni perché lontani
da una retorica romantica dicevo prima
del considera il paesaggio questo questo
modello di contemplazione o solamente a
fini turistici magari è ben lontani da
quella modalità aromatica noi possiamo
dimostrare di essere competitivi con
l'uso dell'automobile nei tempi nei
costi e al tempo stesso incrementare la
qualità della vita
se noi riusciamo a dimostrare questi tre
assetti allora cambia tutto
allora non è che dobbiamo svegliarci al
mattino pensando di dover migliorare il
mondo perché nella migliore delle
ipotesi almeno a me capita spesso non so
a voi io penso
la prima cosa che penso al mattino è
come non peggiorare la qualità della mia
vita
sostanzialmente quindi anche una logica
difensiva attenzione non c'è niente di
difensiva invece tutto questo neanche
nella strategia europea perché la
strategia europea è una strategia di
crescita cioè ci sta dicendo banale
all'estremo abbiamo imparato dopo 20 30
anni che con la cultura si mangia
adesso possiamo imparare un po più in
fretta che con l'ambiente si mangia cioè
l'ambiente da salvare
diventa l'ambiente che salva con
l'ambiente si costruiscono i presupposti
per un nuovo modello di vita quotidiano
per nuovi lavori e per qualcosa che
funzioni finalmente secondo un'ottica di
economia pulita e circolare questa è la
grande differenza
ora cosa serve per questa cosa
beh a ferrara la stiamo già trovando ma
può funzionare anche altrove
serve sicuramente una rete capillare e
badate per organizzare questa rete non
ci vogliono le economie che servono per
organizzare le grandi infrastrutture
non so se sapete quanto può costare un
chilometro di autostrada non meno di 20
milioni di euro un chilometro di
autostrada
non è che te ne fai qualcosa di un
chilometro fare un po perché servono
facciamo conto che questa cosa la rete
capillare di cui parliamo solo nella
provincia di ferrara quei famosi 2.600
chilometri quadrati costi sei chilometri
d'autostrada non di più
sta parlando di ricucitura ciclabili
pulizie sponda di nuovi approdi
rigenerazione stazioni ferroviarie e
quant'altro bene cosa serve anche però
servono tecnologie smart perché non ci
dobbiamo muovere agilmente abbiamo detto
prima tempi di percorrenza che
sostituisse sostituiscono le distanze
muoversi agilmente significa tecnologia
smart che ti permettono una logica che
si direbbe economisti direbbero just in
time permette effettivamente di muoversi
al bisogno
sostanzialmente ma serve anche un nuovo
processo di gestione una nuova
governance si direbbe questa nuova
governance
dobbiamo inventarlo dobbiamo costruirla
con un trasporto pubblico addirittura un
trasporto pubblico privato che possa
organizzare e governare
le quattro reti sovrapposte ora cosa sta
accadendo sta accadendo che in tutto
questo abbiamo ottenuto dei risultati
molto buoni
ci siamo costituiti in associazione ma
quello era semplice non è che hai
bisogno di un premio per fare quello
serve molto poco in realtà abbiamo vinto
due progetti europei che ci hanno
permesso di costruire degli studi di
fattibilità per capire bene dove dove
andare a parare
ci hanno permesso di realizzare in corso
di realizzazione un masterplan
intermodale su tutta la provincia di
ferrara terra e acqua ci hanno permesso
soprattutto di organizzare due progetti
pilota
l'anno scorso ad ottobre a vigarano e
quest'anno anzi siete tutti invitati
sabato 3 domenica 4 ottobre ha paura la
costruzione del nuovo approdo di paura
cosa vuol dire approdo qualcuno potrebbe
dire va bene tutto questo casino per un
approdo
sì tutto questo casino per un approdo
perché quello non è solo un approdo non
è solo un nuovo pontile quello è il
nucleo di un sistema che permette al
sistema di rigenerarsi perché
rigenerazione territoriale nuove
economie miglioramento della qualità
della vita e coesione sociale
sono i dati fondativi che derivano da
questo sistema dove la mobilità
sostenibile solo una premessa perché gli
ap i nodi di questo sistema possono
garantire il recupero di tutte quelle
aree fragili di cui ha fatto il nostro
paese il tutte quelle aree interne di
cui è fatto il nostro paese che non ha
fatto di metropoli fatto odiare piccole
fragili proprio deboli che devono essere
riviste rivitalizzate aree che hanno per
tutto il loro significato aree che non
contano e che possono riprendere a
contare se la rete arriva e se dimostra
che competitiva con l'uso
dell'automobile
ecco che se noi dimostriamo queste cose
andiamo incontro anche alle esigenze e
che abbiamo sulla manutenzione
dell'ambiente quindi non dobbiamo più
aspettare il disastro ex poste puoi
trovare i soldi da qualche parte ma
utilizziamo l'ambiente loro manutengoli
giorno come si fa con le autostrade con
un'ottimizzazione dei costi incredibile
ecco perché mi permetto di dire anche
memore delle spese che stiamo avendo
paura che questa cosa già nella
responsabilità perché la collettività
si nutre di aspettative perché sa di
poter contare finalmente alcune sa
qualcosa sa di poter finalmente
scegliere dove stare e come stare
sostanzialmente una piccola rivoluzione
civile mi sta chiamando
[Applauso]
[Musica]
mourinho
beh
[Musica]
[Applauso]